Aircraft stability is one of the most
important things you need to learn if
you want to improve your flying
abilities as a pilot. But for some
reason, a lot of instructors will tell
you that you can just throw it out the
window once you pass a written test. But
that's not true
whatsoever. Welcome to Free Pilot
Training. I'm Josh and today I'm talking
to you about aircraft stability and what
makes an airplane stable because this is
a really important building block for
learning how to fly an airplane. But
what the heck is stability? Well,
stability is the ability of an aircraft
to correct for disturbances in its
equilibrium and return itself to its
original flight path. Now, I know that
this is a $10 definition. So, for those
of you who are kind of stupid like me,
let me give you an example. Let's say
I'm flying this little airplane right
here and all of a sudden my nose gets
pushed up by turbulence. If I'm flying a
stable airplane, the airplane is going
to want to pitch back down to its
original flight path. I'll explain why
that is in a minute, but it's important
to remember that most training airplanes
like Cessna 172s or Piper Cherokees are
designed to be super stable, and that's
because a stable airplane is easier to
control. Keep in mind, some airplanes
are designed to be less stable on
purpose. Take a look at this fighter
jet. Fighter aircraft like this are
designed to be less stable so they can
be more maneuverable. They can turn
super sharp and they have the ability to
change their direction at the drop of a
hat. But aircraft like this that are
less stable are a lot harder to control.
Remember that a stable aircraft is
easier to control. Now, when we're
discussing aircraft stability, it's
important to remember that all three
axes are considered when an aircraft is
designed. Hopefully, you remember the
three axes we talked about in the last
lesson because we're going to be
building on that discussion today. If
you don't, here's a quick reminder.
First, we've got the lateral axis, which
runs laterally across the aircraft. Then
we have the longitudinal axis which runs
the length of the aircraft. And then we
have the vertical axis which runs the
height of the aircraft. And once again,
these axes go through the aircraft's
center of gravity. Now, when we're
talking about stability, it's important
to know that there are two different
kinds of stability that affect these
axes. Static stability and dynamic
stability. Static stability is the
initial tendency of the aircraft after
the equilibrium has been disturbed. In
other words, what is your airplane's
immediate reaction after you make a
control input or you get pushed around
by the wind or something and your
airplane moves around one of the three
axes? For example, let's say you're
flying along and you pitch the nose of
your airplane up to 5° nose high. You
use the elevator to move the airplane up
around its lateral axis. What is the
airplane's initial tendency? Well, if
the airplane's initial tendency is to
pitch back down, that means your
aircraft has positive static stability.
On the other hand, if your airplane's
initial tendency is to continue straight
ahead at that same fivederee attitude,
we would say that this aircraft has a
neutral static stability. This simply
means that whatever control inputs you
make, the airplane stays right where you
put it. Or if turbulence rolls your wing
into a 5deree bank, that wing is going
to stay right where it's at. But an
airplane could also be designed with a
negative static stability. Most of you
guys are never going to fly an airplane
like this. But if an aircraft has
negative static stability, it is going
to keep moving whichever direction the
control input was made. For example,
let's say I yawed my airplane to the
right with my right rudder pedal. An
airplane with negative static stability
would have an initial tendency of
continuing that yaw to the right and
then you'd be in a flat spin to the
right. But once again, your training
airplane is designed to have positive
static stability. So this isn't really
going to be a thing for you. But take a
look at this F-14 Tomcat in a flat spin
that's experiencing this exact thing.
Fighter aircraft are designed to have
negative static stability so they can do
crazy stuff in combat. Boy, that looks
difficult to control, doesn't it? I'll
take my stable airplane any day. Okay,
so static stability is an airplane's
initial tendency once the equilibrium
has been disturbed. But now I want to
talk to you about dynamic stability. But
before I do that, I want to ask you a
question. Are you trying to get your
private pilot certificate? If so, did
you know that you need an endorsement
from an instructor before you can take
the written exam? That's because the
FAA's private pilot written exam is
really difficult and the FAA wants to
make sure that you're ready. Now, this
series here on YouTube is completely
free. But if you need that endorsement,
probably one of the cheapest ways to get
that is with my premium ground course on
freepilotraining.net. That course
includes these videos, reading
assignments, quizzes, practice tests,
and the endorsement once you're ready.
And all that is only $50 compared to
most ground courses which are usually
around $300. So if you're enjoying these
videos, please consider checking that
out after this video. Okay, let's go
back to talking about dynamic stability.
In a nutshell, dynamic stability is an
airplane's response to a change in the
equilibrium over time. Remember, if an
airplane has positive static stability,
its initial tendency will be to go back
towards its original position. But what
happens after that is what determines
our dynamic stability. Let's say we
pitch the nose of the airplane up. We
know that our training airplane has a
positive static stability. So, the nose
is going to pitch right back down, but
the nose doesn't pitch down exactly
where it was. Training airplanes are
designed so that the nose moves down
below its original position, but at a
slightly shallower pitch attitude. And
guess what? Once again, our airplane is
stable. So, it's designed to pitch back
up and then down again and then up and
so on. Now, if an airplane has positive
dynamic stability, these oscillations
are going to get smaller and smaller
until they're completely unnoticeable.
This is a good thing for training
airplanes. Positive dynamic stability
makes it super easy to get the airplane
under control because we can use really
small control inputs. And if we go too
far, the airplane will eventually
correct itself back to where it needs to
be. And that's why this lesson is so
important. New pilots don't typically
have a good understanding of dynamic
stability and because of that they tend
to overcontrol the airplane. Now, we'll
talk more about this in a minute, but
first let's talk about the two other
types of dynamic stability that some
airplanes have. Let's say we pitch the
nose up again, but this time it went
back to the same position down below and
then it pitched back up to the same
position and those oscillations never
got smaller. This is what we call
neutral dynamic stability. And this
isn't really something you want because
anytime you did anything with the
controls, the airplane is just going to
oscillate the entire time after you made
a control input. Another type of
stability is called negative dynamic
stability. This is what we'd call it if
we made a control input and those
oscillations just got further and
further apart instead of getting smaller
and smaller. Once again, this would not
be desirable either because any tiny
little bump or anything would make it go
completely haywire within a few
oscillations. So, we want the airplane
to come back to its original position.
That's going to make it easier to
control the aircraft. Now, you're
probably still scratching your head over
all this, and that's because this
training requires you to understand two
different topics at the same time. So,
we had a little bit of a chicken and egg
situation, but once I explain some of
the design features of your training
aircraft and how they improve the
stability of your airplane, this is all
going to make way more sense. Keep in
mind to fully understand this, we've got
to talk about how stability relates to
the three axes of our aircraft. Now,
this part can be a little bit confusing,
so take your time here and rewatch this
segment if you need to. First, let's
talk about how we get longitudinal
stability in an airplane. Remember, an
airplane moves perpendicular to the axis
that it's rotating on. So, longitudinal
stability is achieved by the proper
balancing of the lateral axis. And once
again, I like to call this the pitch
axis because the airplane pitches up and
down along the lateral axis of our
aircraft. Now, in order for an aircraft
manufacturer to get the airplane to be
longitudinally stable on that lateral
axis, the airplane must balance
perfectly on its wing. But this is
easier said than done. First of all, at
which point on the wing must the
aircraft be balanced. A wing is designed
so that most of the upper surface
creates lift, but that lift averages out
to one main spot in which that lift is
concentrated. This is what we refer to
as the center of lift or center of
pressure. And your airplane literally
balances on this spot as if the aircraft
is a basket hanging in the sky from this
point. Now, the center of gravity is the
spot where the average weight is
concentrated. So, as you can imagine, if
we were to place the center of gravity
directly beneath the center of lift,
everything would be balanced out nicely.
But airplane manufacturers don't do
that. Instead, they put the center of
gravity slightly in front of the center
of lift so that the nose of the aircraft
is intentionally heavy. And there's
actually a really good reason for this.
First of all, we do not care if the
airplane is balanced when we're sitting
on the ground. What we want is for the
airplane to be balanced while we're
actually flying. Because of that, most
airplanes are designed with a horizontal
stabilizer on the tail, which actually
produces a down force while the airplane
is flying. And the way it does that is
by having a slightly negative angle of
attack. I like to tell students that
it's basically an upside down wing back
here. Keep in mind the center of gravity
doesn't actually move, but the apparent
center of gravity does move and that's
because the tail actually starts pushing
down when you start picking up air speed
and that creates a downforce which
balances your airplane out on its center
of lift. In fact, did you know that you
can actually adjust the amount of tail
downforce that your aircraft is
producing? So, your airplane will be
perfectly balanced for the speed that
it's flying. Yes, this is what we call
trim. And you're going to be using this
a lot when you start flying. Every time
you change your speed, you should be
adjusting the trim so that your airplane
is properly balanced and your apparent
center of gravity is aligned with your
center of lift. This is going to make it
way easier for you to control your
aircraft. Now, here's where things start
to get really interesting. Once a stable
airplane has been properly balanced, it
will almost fly itself. In fact, if you
understand this concept right now,
you're going to be light years ahead of
other student pilots when you actually
get into the airplane and you start your
flight training. Let's say I'm out
cruising around and I bounce out my
airplane properly with my trim set to
the speed that I'm flying. What will
happen if I pitch the nose of my
airplane down? Well, I'll speed up,
won't I? That means my tail back here
will create more downforce. And if the
tail creates more downforce, then the
nose will pitch back up, won't it? And
when that happens, if my aircraft is
trimmed properly, these oscillations
will get smaller and smaller until I'm
back to flying at a level attitude. And
once again, this is called positive
dynamic stability. So, always keep your
airplane trimmed up. That trim improves
your dynamic stability on the pitch
axis. As you can see, the two things
that affect our longitudinal stability
are the center of gravity and the
downforce created by the tail. We'll be
talking about that more in the next
lesson on controllability. But it's
really important to know that
longitudinal stability depends on these
two things. Next, we have lateral
stability. And lateral stability occurs
along the longitudinal axis of an
aircraft. Keep in mind there are a few
different ways that airplane
manufacturers achieve lateral stability
when they design an airplane. But in
this video, I'm only going to explain
the two most common designs that you're
going to run into during your training.
Dihedral and the kill effect. Some
airplanes are designed so that the outer
tip of the wing is higher than the wing
route. This is what we call dihedral.
And this design is usually a little more
pronounced on lowwing airplanes that
can't take advantage of the kill effect.
Let's say your airplane rolls to the
left because of some turbulence that
pushed up your right wing. When this
happens, the wing is not lifted straight
up. Instead, it's lifted in the
direction of the turn. Because of this,
an airplane will typically sides slip
into a yaw away from the direction of
the roll. This is one of the things that
causes adverse yaw. Now, we talked a
little bit about this in our lesson on
spins, but in that video, I told you
that the aileron that is lowered
increases the drag on that raised wing.
But that's not the only thing that
causes your airplane to yaw away from
the turn. The other thing is the
horizontal component of lift, which
we'll be talking about more in an
upcoming video. But once again, when
that wing gets picked up, this causes
the wing to yaw away from the turn. If
an airplane's wings were perfectly
straight and you rolled the aircraft,
the airplane would continue to roll past
where you wanted it to go, even after
you move the yolk back to a neutral
position. This is what happens in an
airplane with negative static stability.
There's nothing to keep the airplane
stable and move it back to its
equilibrium. But in addition to that,
the airplane would yaw away from the
direction of the turn because of adverse
yaw and it would just stay in a slip
throughout the turn. But in most
airplanes, especially low wings, they
typically have a dihedral built into the
wings. And this causes the wing in front
or the leading wing to be at a higher
angle of attack because of that extra
angle in the wing design. Because of
this extra angle, this leading wing is
at a higher angle of attack, which means
it will create more lift and drag, which
rolls us back to level flight. I know
this can be kind of confusing since this
lower wing is at a higher angle of
attack, but this is made possible
because of the wing shape and that
dihedral angle. An airplane without that
dihedral would not want to move back to
its original roll attitude unless there
was something else that caused it to do
that. That's positive static stability.
Dihedral gives an airplane that initial
tendency to move back into position. And
that dihedral angle is carefully chosen
so that if something causes your wing to
roll, it's going to roll back. And those
oscillations are going to get smaller
and smaller until they're completely
gone. And that's what we call positive
dynamic stability. The next design
feature that can improve an airplane's
lateral stability is something called
the kill effect. This is something
that's only present in high-wing
aircraft. And the way the kill effect
works is very similar to the pendulum of
an old clock. What? You don't know what
that is? Oh, well, in that case, let's
say you tied your cell phone on a string
and swung it upward. What would happen
to your phone? Yeah, it'd move back,
wouldn't it? And the same thing happens
in a highwing aircraft. Remember, an
airplane balances on its center of lift.
And when you look at an airplane from
the front like this, the center of lift
is actually concentrated up here in the
center of your wings. Unless, of course,
you're stupid and you put way too much
weight in one of the wings or something.
That can happen, by the way, especially
in bigger airplanes with lots of fuel.
Anyway, the center of lift is up here,
and the airplane center of gravity is
somewhere down here. And once again, the
airplane balances on its center of lift.
So if we roll the aircraft, the weight
is shifted up, but what goes up must
come down. And that means that this
weight will try to bring the airplane
back to level flight. And this tendency
to go back to level flight is something
known as the kill effect. All right,
last but not least, we need to talk
about directional stability. And
directional stability mainly affects the
aircraft's yaw axis. Once again, we want
our training aircraft to be stable. So
airplane manufacturers design these
aircraft so that they'll have good
directional stability. And they do this
by installing a vertical stabilizer of
some kind or some fins on the back of
your aircraft. This in turn causes
something called the weather vein
effect. Anytime the vertical stabilizer
is not aligned with the relative wind,
the relative wind will push the tail
back into position. A lot like a weather
vein. It's a really simple concept, but
it works really, really well to achieve
vertical stability along the yaw axis.
Now, you might be asking yourself, why
should I care about all this stuff? In
fact, I can guarantee you that some of
your flight instructors are going to
tell you guys that this is something you
need to know for the written exam, but
then you could just throw it out the
window once you start your flight
training. Do not do that. If your flight
instructor tells you this, tell them
that Josh says he's This is
something that will really help you to
understand how to control the airplane.
And that's because new pilots tend to
overcontrol the aircraft when they're
first getting started. This is because
they don't understand that anytime you
move the controls, a stable airplane is
going to try to move back to its
original position. And if you know that,
you'll be ready for it and adjust your
controls accordingly. In fact, if you
watch an experienced pilot control an
airplane, you'll notice that anytime
they move the controls, they typically
move them in the opposite direction soon
after to keep the aircraft oscillations
to a minimum. But for most folks getting
started, they wait until the stability
of the aircraft moves them to the other
side of the control input and then they
use the controls to get the aircraft
back into position. But had they just
taken their hands off the controls,
these oscillations would have just got
smaller and smaller because the training
aircraft has great dynamic stability.
And when you overcontrol an airplane
like this, this is what we call a pilot
induced oscillation. Pilot induced
oscillations are almost always caused by
a poor understanding of aircraft
stability. That's why you can tell your
instructor that he's a dingleberry with
love. Do it with love. Hey, I want to
thank you guys for watching today's
video. If you enjoyed it, be sure to
smash that like button for me. And then
also don't forget to check out my $50
premium private pilot ground course.
That's over on free pilotraining.net.
And then once you do that, you can check
out the next video right here. And I'll
see you guys over there. See you.